[Music]
all right let's go back out to Richmond
Virginia and talk to Sarah with an H
what's up
Sarah hey how's it going paryan what are
you up
to just sitting at home with the
cold um that sounds awful what's up yeah
yeah I just reached out because um my
husband and I have been married for
about s years and he just really
struggles with a lot of anger and a lot
of um anxiety and it just manifests
itself
into a lot of yelling and screaming and
um we have two young kids I'm pregnant
with our
third um and you know then on top of
that if he gets mad enough at me he'll
break things like he'll Break um you
know gift GI that I've given him or
he'll break uh he'll like smash food or
you know things that I've bought for
myself excuse me or that type of thing
and it's just really hard for me to know
how to handle it and I guess that's my
question is how do
I how do I navigate this in a way that's
healthy because you know my first
instinct when he smashes something that
I took a lot of time to pick out for him
or that he even asked for himself that I
bought for a birthday present or
something like that my first reaction is
be like well I'm never gonna buy you
anything ever again you know but I don't
I don't want to be vindictive I don't
want to be um bitter so I'm just trying
to figure out how I am supposed to
respond in a way that's protecting
myself and protecting my
kids um yeah
oh man Sarah can I just can I just cut
to the Chase and be super honest on some
things is that okay
yeah um I I think it's honest I want to
be as honest as I can um this is one of
those rare calls that
uh it it tightens my upper
chest my wife would say she could see
across the room I see your jaw starting
to clinch and we need to
go yeah cuz she I'm about to get myself
into trouble okay this is one of those
moments and so I want you to know that
any in a world that you live in the
world you live in right now you will be
especially attuned to the sharpness in
my voice and I want you to know this is
not directed at you okay yeah yeah okay
and I am also talking in circles a
little bit to give my chance myself a
chance to
breathe okay okay the anger your H your
husband's anger is not the problem here
yeah your husband is is a freaking
toddler
yeah and he acts like a
child and a child in a man's body can
hurt somebody
irreparably
okay and you're focused on well then I'm
just not going to make you gifts anymore
I'm focused on the women I've visited in
hospitals before who have their faces
knocked
in yeah okay
a anxiety and anger don't manifest into
smashing things toddlers
do immature grown men do it's not a
result of what your husband's struggling
with it's a choice he is making in a
moment yeah or it's a choice he is
making to not deal with in the moments
that he's not anxious and
enraged okay I do know some there is
some psychological issues where people
go quote unquote blind with rage fine
but then it's their job to deal with it
Upstream before they're blinded right
yeah and I'm speaking boldly about this
because I was a guy that was so buried
with anxiety I couldn't breathe and my
impulse was to smash things and I didn't
cuz I'm an adult not cuz I'm better than
anybody but because I'm a grownup and I
went and sought professional health help
yeah
right so you're not GNA like what I'm
telling you to do next okay I just need
you to know that that I'm on your
team okay
um and I I know there's a financial
reality to this I know there's a just a
reality reality to
this but if it's safe he gets a final
powerful written written in stone with
fire
boundary if you yell in this house again
if you smash something again if you
scream in this house again I'm leaving
with our kids or you're leaving
period if most of the time people call
the show and they and they water down
what's actually going on they sanitize
it a bit it's hard to say it out
loud
yeah and what I just have a gut feeling
that's what you're having to do right
now and I honor that so I'm not going to
push you on it but if that conversation
can't be had for safety
reasons then you go find a safe place to
go for you and your two kids and your
third one on the way yeah and then you
communicate that in writing or through
an
attorney but when my toddler when my
daughter or my son was a
toddler I can't you can't explain things
to someone who is acting like a
six-year-old cuz they're six yeah yeah
and someone who's an adult body and goes
and grabs gift and smashes them just to
go
haaha that's somebody who is being led
by their inner
child
yeah all right so I just said a lot of
heavy
stuff what do you feel do you think I'm
right am I crazy you push back on me no
I I think you're right I've you know
thankfully you know I we're already
seeing counselor I'm I have seen
counselors myself I've got you know
mentors and things like that that I've
kind of talked through this situation
within everybody you know pretty much
agrees with that especially so some
think that I should just go ahead and
leave others think that like what you
said um if it's a conversation that I
can have in a safe way and I've pretty
much already told him that you know I've
I've said
if this happens again you know I'm
leaving and I'm taking the kids with me
until you can prove that you are working
on yourself and um and seeking the help
that you need because I I've tried
really long and and I think that's
what's hard is like we'll have you know
a good month or a good couple months or
a good couple weeks or things like that
and and I then it just kind of like
lulls you into like a false sense of
security almost of like and then just
being so busy like I've got two small
kids I wear full-time being pregnant
like it's just
um it's a lot to like to deal with you
know 100% a third child that you're
having to like parent almost you know
listen that's exactly what you're doing
you're parenting a third child except
this third child has humongous
muscles yeah
and if a toddler hit you czy is he's
like he was a police officer for many
years like he's seen women who have gone
through this you know he's
seen but he just like I don't think that
he believes like he fully understands
that like hitting me is wrong or hitting
our kids is wrong but I don't think he
because like this is the way that his
family has dealt with conflict he comes
from a very toxic family and not that
that excuses Behavior because he could
be different but it's like he just does
not see why that's why it's a
problem to yell and scream why it's a
problem to like as long as he's not
hitting me to like take his aggression
out on like an inanimate object you know
and so sometimes he'll be sorry and then
other times he'll be like oh well if you
had made me so upset yeah
that's God piss me off that's a freaking
coward yeah blaming you for his childish
behavior because he always always has a
choice always and you do too yeah you do
too I think the challenge here is you
are telling him you have to stop doing
your thing because what you're doing is
wrong and what he's telling you is I
don't think it is and I think that's the
wrong way to go about
it the more eff way to go about go about
it is this you being Sarah say I will
not live in a
house where the man in the home smashes
things when he gets in a temper tantrum
period if you want to be married to
me you will not smash things in this
home I won't be in a home where somebody
yells at me or my children period yeah
and if you want to disagree with me your
lawyer can talk to mind so what you're
doing is you're not saying you need to
do these things cuz these things are
wrong cuz he's telling you I don't think
they are what you're saying is I won't
be a part of that
life yeah most people when they get to
where you are and they get right up to
this boundary line that they're about to
draw really firmly in the ground have a
couple of challenges one is economic it
doesn't sound like that's where you are
you could get an apartment and y'all
could be okay is that fair yeah I have
family in the area could live with by
the way are your family telling you to
get the hell out for a long
time there yeah I mean I haven't told
them that he smashes stuff you know they
know that I'm kind of his verbal
punching bag because they've seen it in
some cases you know they've told
me you know if you ever need a break
like you don't have to call just come
like we'll be here you know so they're
very supportive that's them doing a
pretty lukewarm job of trying to tell
you um yeah if you're ready to run we
got you yeah um without wanting to
trying to overstep their bounds if you
were my if you were related to me I
would I would way overstep my bounds but
I tend to do that all the time um yeah
here's the other
thing often if economics are okay
there's a really powerful identity
problem yeah those women can't make it
work yeah those women quote unquote
break up their family single moms are
fill in the blank fill in the blank fill
in the
blank
yeah yeah and I you know I have a very
strin relationship with his family his
mom for many years has tried to break
our marriage up and um she's just a very
manipulative person and so I've Been
Told
by her you know that we're never going
to last you're never going to like
you're never going to make it you're
going to you know she's told my husband
like you better watch what you say
around her because she's going to take
everything from you and like take your
kids from you because that's what her
husband tried to do to her you know so I
know that there is an element of Pride
there of like you know I don't want to
prove this horrible person right you
know that I essentially and I know this
is
she doesn't get a vote she doesn't get a
vote I wouldn't let that woman speak one
whisper into my mind or my heart
yeah not as far I mean I I mean
she what that what that becomes is this
a fear that others are going to judge
you as harshly as you're judging
yourself right now yeah and I'm gonna
ask you to
stop you deserve to be safe you deserve
to walk into your own home pregnant with
child number three from a day of of of
full-time
work going home to a place where you can
drop everything and
laugh and be greeted by a former police
officer who gets the hell that is
women's lives these days and greet you
with a hug and a cup of tea and some
laughter yeah right or a funny dance or
a joke or at least picked up your
underwear not you walk into your home
and your body's preparing for war yeah
right yeah you deserve that that baby
that is just bathing in cortisol and
adrenaline right now deserves that yeah
everybody in that house your two babies
deserve that yeah and I want you just to
back just just be honest with yourself
and look back and say has anything I've
done or said or threatened has any of
that worked
no yeah so at some point you got to try
something new and if you listen to the
show for any length of time I almost
never tell somebody they gotta they got
to get
out but if your friends are telling you
and your family's
offering and I can tell in your voice
you're not telling me
everything it's a lot to tell it's a lot
to I know I'm not blaming you I wouldn't
tell some weirdo on a podcast
either but I think you got to get with a
friend or two because also it's going to
be very emotional it's going to be heavy
and I'm not just saying emotional
because you're a pregnant woman I'm
saying if I was doing this I'd get
emotional about it okay I would have to
have a couple of people in my corner to
say am I making a right move what's the
um what's a safe apartment close to
schools or what's Child Care going to
look like I want to have all those
things lined up do I have a bank account
with my own money in it yeah I get some
people that will think it through with
you
and if you think you can have one last
conversation that's safe I'm all about
it I'm all about it yeah but if you
don't I don't don't feel compelled
to or it might be we can have a
conversation after I have locked the
gates because you're you're not
listening to my
boundaries yeah and I I think it just
feels like he's almost like a different
person like when this stuff happens you
know it's not he's generally like a
pretty pleasant person when he's in a
good mood and things are going well but
it's just like he does not know how to
handle life just in general like stress
and that's his job that's his job you
cannot solve that for him yeah that's
his
Adventure well and it's like just what
you said about you know a toddler he
wouldn't let our toddler behave that way
no no no no know and by the way anger is
good anger points us to something that
we care about anger is not a bad
thing it's what we do with
it then he chooses to abuse his wife
with it he chooses to create in little
kids a nervous system that will never
regulate until they get professional
help that's what he's choosing to do
that's on
him those are choices he's making so
what you have to do is to stop waiting
into his choices you've done that you've
done that for a long time and You'
probably put yourself in some pretty
risky dicey
situations
cool what you have to do is to begin to
solve for safety immediately I'm GNA
solve for
safety solve for safety solve for safety
and tell them you call me I'm happy to
talk to
him give him some some uh a pass out of
the madness that he's
in but I don't think this happens
through more talking and more talking
and more talking and more talking and
more
talking I think safety has you have to
solve for safety now and I want you to
ask yourself this has this been slowly
and quietly
escalating because I always look for
trend lines in these situations does
someone just have a bad day and smashed
something and they felt like a
about it and they're so sorry and they
go to make it right or did it start with
slam and hands on a table and then break
a glass and then smash a thing and then
purposely find something you made and
break it to and then start screaming and
cursing if you see this thing
escalating the data would tell me you're
next and I don't want you to be
next reach out to some friends
tonight and let's start making a
plan you're worth being safe and you're
worth being well